-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
After announcing
his 2024 reelection campaign,
President Biden delivered
a speech yesterday
about his economic vision
for the country.
That's right, from now on,
the grandkids are getting $6
in their birthday cards.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Vermont Senator Bernie Sanders
endorsed President Biden
yesterday
and said he will do what he can
to make sure Biden is reelected.
But if Biden loses,
the two of them
can always go back
to heckling the Muppets.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Following recent reports
of Justice Clarence Thomas'
failure to disclose
lavish vacations and gifts
from a wealthy Republican donor,
the Supreme Court released
a three-page
statement yesterday,
signed by all nine justices,
committing to follow,
"foundational ethics
and principles."
Starting now.
I mean, now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay, now! Damn it, Clarence!
That's right,
all nine Supreme Court justices
signed a pledge to follow
"foundational ethics
and principles."
Okay, but it wasn't all nine
of them we were worried about.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, Elena Kagan's
last vacation was
to the Lincoln Memorial.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Took the bus.
[ Laughter ]
In honor
of Lesbian Visibility Week,
the cast of
"The L Word: Generation Q"
yesterday
visited the White House,
said Tucker Carlson
to a house plant.
[ Laughter ]
A top aide to Republican
presidential hopeful
Vivek Ramaswamy
said today
that he will be polling
in second or third place
by the end of the year.
Unless, of course,
a fourth person joins the race.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The USDA announced yesterday
that it is considering
making changes
to limit the amount
of salmonella
in some chicken products.
I'm sorry,
they haven't already?
[ Laughter ]
"We're also considering
a three strikes rule,
if it's secretly a pigeon.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
You can get away with it twice."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ben and Jerry's cofounder
Ben Cohen
recently launched a new cannabis
line called Ben's Best Blnz.
[ Laughter ]
Hopefully it's a lot
more popular than...
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
That was easy to do
because we had a pack
lying around.
[ Laughter ]
Quarterback Aaron Rodgers
reportedly spent a week
in Costa Rica
at a spiritual healing center
before officially signing
with the New York Jets,
which is like washing your car
right before it rains.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos was
photographed over the weekend
at Coachella
and even he couldn't believe
how much they were charging
for water.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, authorities
in Mexico recently seized
nearly 12,000 tequila bottles
that contained
concentrated liquid meth.
On the bright side,
Margarita night ended
with a completely
spotless house.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.